MARKUS KLUTE: Welcome back
to the last section of 8.20
Special Relativity.
So as we discussed for special
relativity itself, also
general relativity
is a theory which
requires experimental
evidence to be confirmed.
And there's plenty of
experimental evidence
for general relativity.
We talked about a
few examples of them.
But let's go through
this, one by one.
Also, a little bit with
an historical context.
So one of the first experimental
pieces of evidence pointed out
by Einstein was the
procession of mercury
and also of other planets.
This was always this problem
that's a procession of mercury,
deviates from
Newton's prediction
was well known and first
recognized already in 1859.
And it turned out that attempts
to correct this failed.
You can think
about, maybe there's
other objects in the
solar system which
modify the trajectory of
mercury around the sun.
But nothing really
added up correctly.
And then when
Einstein calculated
the effect of the
procession, he found
that it's in good agreement
with the observation.
This was already
very strong evidence
for general relativity effects.
And then there's
gravitational lensing.
And here, this
was first measured
by Dyson and Eddington,
1919, of light
passing the sun in
a total eclipse.
The observation was
in Brazil but also
at the West Coast of Africa.
This wasn't the first
attempt to measure this.
It was an eclipse, a total
eclipse in Argentina in 1912.
But unfortunately,
this expedition
didn't lead to a result,
because it rained out.
There was eclipse
shortly after in 1914,
but that happened during
the Second World War,
and there's long stories and
accounts of how this failed.
But basically, one
of the expeditions
wanted to travel to
Crimea in Russia.
And because Russia was
in war with Germany,
material was confiscated,
and people were imprisoned.
So this was canceled,
if you want,
due to the second
and first World War.
But then in 1919, this
led to the observation
the data was not as clear.
I think there was a little
bit more hope than science
in the interpretation.
So there was-- there was
not a strong evidence,
a strong significance
of the results.
But the evidence,
nevertheless, was there.
And as I was explaining
earlier, that
led to the fame or the
triumph of Einstein,
where really, his
fame resulted out
of the reporting
of those events.
There's more
experimental evidence.
Light travel time
but around or close
to massive object is modified.
We talked about gravitational
time dilation, which can be
measured or has been measured.
Other tests of the equivalent
principle, but also
the observation of
gravitational waves.
Gravitational waves were
predicted by Einstein
by the theory of
general relativity.
And only very recently, we
were able to observe those.
And then, in addition, there
is plenty cosmological tests,
which require a
precise understanding
of general relativity
in order to get
to agreement between
the observations
and the theoretical predictions.
But let's talk about--
let's talk about
gravitational waves.
So those we predicted,
as I was saying,
but they're very, very
difficult to measure.
First, indirect measurement was
performed by Hulse and Taylor.
They were able to study
binary neutron star system.
And because the
orbits of those two
decayed required lots of
energy, and that lots of energy
needs to happen somehow.
And it was theorized or
predicted by general relativity
that that loss of energy
is due to the fact
that gravitational
waves are emitted.
And they received
for their findings
the Nobel Prize in
physics in 1993.
So how are gravitational
waves generated?
You can ask-- I have a
spinning sphere, like our sun.
Would that generate
a gravitational wave?
The answer is no.
It's a symmetrical situation.
There's no change of
the metal distribution.
And therefore, spacetime
is not modified.
But if you have a sphere
with a little bump,
that would create
gravitational waves.
If you have a mass
which is moving by,
maybe two passing galaxies,
that would not directly
create gravitational waves.
But if you have those
galaxies rotating,
or two stars rotating, or
neutron stars rotating,
or black holes rotating
around each other,
those generate
gravitational waves.
And the closer the
object, the higher
the masses of the
objects, the stronger
the gravitational waves are.
So how can you measure
gravitational waves?
Very similar to the
Michael Smalley experiment.
What you want to do
is measure differences
in arms of your interferometer.
And you do this with
very powerful lasers
and with very precise mirrors.
So it's very clear the very same
experiment as Michael Smalley,
just much, much bigger.
So we're talking about
multiple miles of arms
and very powerful
lasers in order
to conduct those experiments.
LIGO, which is one
of those measurement,
of those devices,
experiments, measures
the change in the length
of one arm with a precision
smaller than the
diameter of a proton.
So that's just really--
it's mind-blowing, the
level of precision,
the level of understanding
needed in order
to measure gravitational waves.
But nevertheless,
they succeeded.
So here, you see
two experiments.
LIGO has actually
two experiments,
two of those devices
in the United States.
And there's other experiments
similar worldwide.
You see also highlighted
here, Caltech and MIT.
Those are the leading
communities of the leading
universities in this endeavor.
And then the first observation
of gravitational waves
happened in September 14, 2015.
And this first observation
was rather spectacular
because it was not
just any observation,
but it was the observation of
two collapsing black holes.
So you have two black holes.
They get close to each other,
than they circle each other
and create a new,
heavier black hole.
So the collision of
those two black holes
with masses around 30 times
the mass of the sun, it
actually took place
1.3 billion years ago.
So the gravitational wave
was traveling towards us
for 1.3 billion years.
The energy of about three
times the mass of the sun
was emitted as gravitational
waves in fractions of seconds.
So the huge amount
of energy released
in form of gravitational waves.
The collision happens with
both black holes moving
with half the speed of light.
So this is just a catastrophic
kind of event, in our universe.
And researchers or
faculty at MIT and Caltech
received the Nobel
Prize in physics in 2017
for this discovery, only two
years after the discovery
actually happened--
and very deserved,
very deserved.
Let me close this lecture
by just reminding you
of a quote of Einstein,
which I use in order to start
this very same lecture.
It is true that we are living
through some difficult times,
some turbulent times.
But if you think about
the bigger picture,
I think we're making
a lot of progress
scientifically but
also as humanity.
And I like this quote from
Albert Einstein a lot.
"It is not the result
of scientific research
that ennobles humans and
enriches their nature,
but it's the struggle
to understand
while performing creative and
open-minded intellectual work."
I think if there's
one thing I want
you to take away from this
lecture, it is this quote.
I want you to be encouraged to
be creative, to be open-minded,
to question, and to perform
high-level intellectual work.
Thank you.